[Music]
the long-awaited spider-man no way home
will be released in theaters this
december
and after all the rumors about the
upcoming movie fans are certainly hoping
for a spectacle
so we thought perhaps we could help
shorten the waiting time a bit by
presenting you with a video
that is all about spider-man's best
fights however it is not only about tom
holland's fight as
today we show you the match spider-man
fighting scenes of all movies to date
we find ranking the scenes on the scale
from 1 to 10 a bit too subjective
so we will just list them for you but
enough chatter have fun with the fights
first of all let's play tribute to the
first ever fight scene that of peter vs
flash in the 2002 movie spider-man no
of course we're not talking about the dc
superhero flash but about the school
bully flash
thompson toby maguire vs joe marganiello
in this scene peter is just getting to
know his newly discovered abilities
when he accidentally throws a tray full
of food at his classmate
the student doesn't put up with this
after all he has a reputation to lose
when he tries to beat peter up he
realized that peter now disposes of
unbelievable reflexes
dodging all the blows he demonstrates a
flip and with just one counter attack he
knocks flash to the ground the latter
ends up directly on a teacher who pours
his full tray over him yet again
even though this scene is not as
action-packed as others it must be
included in this list for nostalgia
reasons alone
spectacular fights are not only to be
found in live action films though the
animated film from 2018
also has a few surprises to offer above
all however the movie has succeeded in
integrating the multiverse into the
spider-man saga
thus we do not only see new spider-man
and maz morales but also peter parker
penny parker spider-ham spider-gwen
and spider-man noir in the final battle
the dimensions collapse into each other
and
everyone must face their arch enemies
miles particularly
kingpin not only are the animations
breathtaking the fight in the moving
train in the middle of the mansion chaos
is also simply
epic even though kingpin doesn't have
any abilities worth mentioning
he turns out to be an almost invincible
opponent
with the last of his strength spidey
manages to defeat him and take emotional
revenge for his
uncle at this point if any of you have
not seen the film yet
you should urgently do so it's not for
nothing that the movie won an oscar
peter and gwen stacy were unable to
celebrate their victory over elektra for
too long
as shortly afterwards their mutual
friend harry osborne turned up
unfortunately he's no longer his true
self in order to cure himself of a
genetic disease
he has transformed into the green goblin
now he's out for revenge because spidey
refused to give him his blood before him
to fight set disease
to make matters worse he finds out
spiderman's true identity relatively
quickly due to gwen's presence which
only fuels his rage thus she gets caught
in the crossfire during the fight
between the two friends
even though pierre manages to knock out
the goblin he fails to save his
girlfriend
she tumbles to her death just seconds
after victory
this is one of the most dramatic spidey
fights and probably the first one
without a real happy ending
four are a hero at least now that we
already have toby maguire andrew
garfield and spiderman with the
spider-verse on a list
we must of course slowly but surely get
to the probably most popular spider-man
namely tom holland in his spy
role in the mcu indeed his very first
film introduced michael keaton's vulture
one of the strongest villains to date
he pushes spider-man to his limits
particularly because he's the father of
peter's crush liz allen
in the battle vulture tries to steal a
piece of stark technology sent by happy
in an invisible jet
peter confronts him on a plane which
ends up crashing as a result of the
fight even though vulture manages to
defeat spidey on the ground his damaged
suit explodes as he tries to leave with
a loot
still spider-man wouldn't be the
friendly neighborhood spider if he
didn't rescue the villain from the
flames
and leave him tied up in spider webs for
the police and closed he leaves a little
message behind saying
found flying vulture guy spider-man ps
sorry about your plane
with this small act spider-man finally
earned his place among the avengers
if you want to see arguably one of the
most brutal fights
you have to watch the movie spider-man 3
from 2007
even though the film got rather bad
reviews at the time it is very much
celebrated today
this is mainly due to the mean potential
it has generated most notably peter's
absurd dance in the middle of new york
okay but let's get back to the actual
fight in this one peter finds the
sandman
aka flint marco as is well known he shot
spidey's uncle ben parker
strengthened by the symbiote and driven
by his feelings of revenge they fight in
the subway of new york
here a seemingly friendly spider holds
marco's head against a passing train
causing the sandman to have half his
face
ripped off just like that however the
fight continues
as they are hurled into the sewer system
peter realized that his opponent's weak
point is water and so he attempts to
drown him in a massive flood of water
until he has disintegrated him
completely since spider-man doesn't
usually resort to such brutal methods
we'll blame it on the symbiote's power
uniting with his at this point
despite all its brutality it is still
one of the best combats in any of the
movies
after so much action it is time to get
nostalgic and remember
how spider-man got his name in the tobey
maguire series in the first place
well he get in the cage fight against
the wrestler bonesaw
he entered the match with a rather
embarrassing name of the human spider
even though he had to take some harsh
blows from his opponent at the beginning
he of course quickly gained the upper
hand and sent the wrestler to the ground
with a kick the crowd celebrated him
and wrote the name spider-man and bam
his
alias was born being the only scene that
didn't come from a solo spidey movie
the conflict between spider-man and
ant-man and the first avengers civil war
made it onto the list
obviously you cannot reduce the entire
fight between the avengers to just this
one scene but you must admit that
spidey's wit and especially his
conflicting nature of fighting his own
heroes adds
something special to the whole thing
most importantly his reference to star
wars the empire strikes back is a gem
and underpins his position as everyone's
favorite spidey with nerd tumor
plus he does of course manage to take
down his role model ant-man and ad-hat
style
since venom got his own movie in 2018
hardly anyone thinks about the 2007
version made in spider-man 3.
wrong fully we think since the
introduction of the evil symbiote was
one of the few bright spots in the flick
so was the final fight between peter and
eddie brock
not only will spider-man himself
confront with the time when he was
connected to venom in the fight his best
friend harry also sacrifices himself for
him
yet not in vain as it was only thanks to
him that he found
out that the greatest weakness of the
black monster is sound waves
using the pipes that were lying around
he created so much sound that the
symbiote detaches her from eddie he then
delivered the final blow with one of
harry's pumpkin bombs
eddie brock who no longer wanted to live
without the symbiote also threw himself
into the bomb by the last second
remembering this fight one can only hope
that there will be soon a reunion with
venom in the spider-verse
a special fight scene is the one between
spider-man and mysterio
the decisive battle comes right at the
end of the movie quentin back is
determined to kill peter
he intends to achieve this by creating
one last illusion to defeat spidey
however at the very last second the
friendly neighborhood spider retrieves
his
peter tingle yes we still laugh whenever
we get that word too with this he's able
to dodge
all of the drones through his senses
alone eventually defeating mysterio
however the post-credit scene shows he
still had an ace up his sleeve when he
exposes peter's true identity
and thus lays the foundation for the new
spider-man movie
no way home it is undisputed that 2004's
spider-man 2 is still one of the best
superhero movies of all time
this is despite the mcu and the dceu
emerging later
in particular the battle scene on the
moving train between spider-man and
doctor octopus is actually considered
one of the highlights of the
entire samurai trilogy in the
action-packed scene spidey and doc
ock fight on a train as already
mentioned however peter must not only
cope with the power of his opponent but
also protect the people
inside the vehicle in order to avoid a
long fight octopus sabotages the
controls so as to crash the train
peter is ready to sacrifice his life and
screaming in pain tries to bring the
train to a halt by shooting spiderwebs
at the sides of nearby buildings
with amazing speed and using his own
feet to break
the audience holds its breath while
spidey stops the train at the very last
second
while we said at the beginning that we
weren't going to do a ranking in the
video
this is still our favorite fight scene
out of all the spiderman movies
all the more reason for us to be happy
to welcome back alfred molina as daca in
the upcoming spider-man
no way home those were our favorite
spider-man fighting sequences which one
did you like the most leave us your
opinion in the comments
obviously we know that there are many
more scenes that could have been
included in this video but that may be
subject for
another video if you're already hyped
for spiderman no way home and would like
to find out more about what it is about
and what has already been revealed you
can now follow the link in the top right
corner to watch our preview
see you next time
[Music]
you